MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Next up, we have a
session on Analytics
by Dan Waisberg, who
is super-passionate
about analytics, data
visualization, data-mining,
anything where he can
figure out what's actually
going on behind the scenes.
And if any of you ever launched
a game without analytics in,
he'll probably be really angry.
Here's Dan Waisberg.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL WAISBERG: Thank you.
So I'm the Analytics
Advocate here,
and more than-- I
like data very much,
but I like people to
use data, and my job
is to help people make
better decisions using data.
And every time that
I think about data,
I like to think about, how
does it look like in real life?
And if we can play
this video, please?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-People that bought olives
also bought Chardonnay.
-Oh, all right.
-78% of the people who
need Chardonnay also
bought "What to Do When
He's Not That Into You."
-Well, I'm just wanting
to get some olives, so.
-Why not buy all three?
-Oh yeah.
-Because I don't
really need them.
-It'll give you a total
saving of seven pence.
-I think I'll still
pass, actually.
-Just some wine then.
-No.
Sorry.
I didn't-- no.
Excuse me.
I'm, I'm not buying this wine.
-You sure you want to remove
that item from your basket?
-Yes.
-Why not try something new?
-What, and buy
something totally random
that I've never shown
any interest in?
-Wills and Kate memorial mug?
-Yeah, OK.
I'll take the mug.
Obviously I'm joking, aren't I?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DANIEL WAISBERG: That's how our
users, they feel very often,
and sometimes we're just
trying to help them,
but sometimes we
annoy them, and I
think Analytics is a
great way to understand
when are we annoying them
and when we are helping them.
And another example that I
like-- so if you were-- I
mean, let's suppose you
have an offline store,
and you want to know what's
going on with your users,
and you just stand in front
of your store and count people
coming in.
What kind of things
they're looking at,
what kind of transportation
they're coming with.
And then you would come up with
a table like this one, right?
You have users, people.
You have your app,
which is a store.
You have device, vehicle.
And then you could
start understanding more
about these people.
So people coming using--
people coming with trucks,
they bounce a lot
because maybe you
don't have a parking
lot for trucks.
But then you see
that those that do
manage to find a parking
place, they buy a lot of stuff
from the store.
So you could optimize your
store for trucks, right?
And the same with devices.
On the-- with apps.
And I just moved to
the UK one year ago,
and this winter, we
did a trip to Wales.
And that's a very nice place.
And we went to
one of these pubs.
And I was struck
with this quote,
"You're a stranger
here, but only once."
And I think that's the ultimate
objective of Analytics,
is to understand people
from the first time
that they come to the app, or
to a website, or to any place.
Because they're
giving us so much
information about what they're
doing, what kind of things
they like, where
they're coming from.
So we could use this
information to provide a better
experience for the users.
And so, just to summarize,
the two most important things
on Analytics is, first
of all, uncovering bugs
and opportunities.
So like the example
with the trucks, right?
We're uncovering something,
that the app is not
working for version
Android 4.1, or whatever,
so we have to fix this bug.
And then learning valuable
and actionable information
about the users,
something that you
can use to make the
experience better.
So I'm going to try to
provide a few techniques to do
that with Analytics.
And the first one that I think
is the single most important
thing on Analytics
is segmentation.
And I'm going to use two case
studies from LEGO building
that I think exemplify very well
the two types of segmentations
that we have.
Because, after all, data
is just like bricks.
You can use bricks to
build different things,
and data is the same.
We got this set in January,
and it has 3,803 bricks,
and I think it is the
largest LEGO set on Earth.
And we were thinking
about-- would it
be easy or hard to build it?
And we were very
surprised when we
opened the box--
it's a huge box--
and then you have
four boxes, right?
One through four.
Of course, you'll
open number one first.
And then you get dozens
and dozens of plastic bags.
And then, when you open
those plastic bags,
they have even
smaller plastic bags.
So LEGO, they did all
the heavy-lifting for us,
so that we can accomplish
the mission, which
is building the Death Star.
Right?
So they're doing
something-- they're
planning for us to
accomplish a mission, which
is build something.
Second case study
is Angry Birds.
Now my son likes Angry
Birds, and he likes LEGO,
so it's very natural
that he would
want to build Angry
Birds out of LEGO.
And if you go to your
LEGO room, and you
find something like that, it's
pretty impossible to build.
Because for every red brick,
it will take five minutes,
and you know it would
end up taking weeks
to build a red Angry Bird.
But if you have something
like that-- by the way,
this is the LEGO Factory,
and the actual set designers,
they sit on those
places, on those tables
and they-- everything
that they need,
they know where to find, right?
So when they have an
idea, they're not,
they're not organizing these
for a mission-- like the Death
Star-- they're organizing these,
so that they can find whatever
they need when they
need it, on the fly.
This is what you come up
with, LEGO Angry Birds.
And how this relates
to Google Analytics--
so I believe that segmentation
can be divided into two.
So it's Mission-Driven
Segmentation and On the Fly
Segmentation, and I'm
going to show here
a few examples on how to do
that on your Google Analytics.
So first of all, Mission-Driven.
So the number one technique
is creating views.
So we have this-- if you
logged into Google Analytics
for an app, you would see
something like that, right?
New Users, Active Users, Top
Devices, Country, and this
is very nice, very beautiful.
I love the UI, but it's not
very actionable as it is.
So we have to do
some segmentation
to understand better.
If, for example, I am
responsible for my app
in the US, and there's
someone else for the UK.
So I'm going to look every
day, maybe every week,
I'm going to look for
the US numbers, right?
And I don't really care
about the UK numbers.
Maybe once a month I
want to compare them,
but on a daily basis, I
want to know about US.
Now, if that is the case,
every time that I get here,
I have to segment, right?
I have to start a
new segmentation
and start looking into the data,
but I can do that, so that,
if I create a View, every
time that I log into Google
Analytics, I'll see
just US users of my app.
So it's very easy.
You go to admin.
You'll see all your views, and
then you create a new view,
and then you can
create a filter.
And filters you can create for
anything on Google Analytics,
or for most of the dimensions.
And here, for example,
you can create a view just
for an app version--
for example, app version
number two-- and you're
very focused on looking
at the difference
between the versions,
and then you can
create different views
for different versions.
So that's number one, and
there's a big advantage of it
is that it saves a lot
of time, so instead
of every time that you're
going to Google Analytics,
you segment the data,
you can plan for it,
so that it's segmented
when you need it.
Now Mission-Driven number two.
Most people know this
woman, a princess,
and so every person has
three types of identifiers.
So the first one is a
personal identifier.
So it's something that we carry
with us throughout life, right?
Our gender, the color of the
skin, the color of our eyes,
so things that we don't change
every day, or every week,
or every year.
And then there is
daily identifiers,
which are things
that we start them--
we start the morning with
them-- like our hair,
or makeup, or earrings--
and then we keep them
until the end of
the day, and then we
change them for tomorrow.
And then there are the
ambient identifiers,
which are things that we
change every time that we
get into a new ambience--
things like coats,
or sunglasses, or guns, for
those of you who like it.
And Google Analytics is
divided in the exact same way.
We have Visitor Level custom
dimensions, which are things
that we want to measure
across visits, right?
So if someone purchases
something on the app,
I want to know every time
that this person comes back,
that this person is
a returning buyer.
Or this person is, for example,
a specific type of visitor,
if we have this on your game.
And then you have Visit,
or session, Level custom
dimensions.
So if you have-- when
someone opens an app,
sometimes you have a promotion,
promotion of the day--
you can try
different promotions,
and then see which
one drives purchases.
Right?
And then this is relevant
just for the current visit,
so you don't want to keep
that for the next visit
as well, because it probably
doesn't affect the next visit
purchase.
And then you have Page Level,
screen level, dimensions,
which are things that, if you
have different games that you
want to group, things that
happen on different games,
you can use the screen level.
Now this has a
very big advantage
that you can use your
own definitions, right?
So if you have different
types of players,
you want to see those players
listed on Google Analytics,
and you can segment behavior
on Google Analytics based
on your own definitions,
which is a great advantage.
Now, let's talk a little bit
about On the Fly Segmentation.
And just-- the Mission-Driven
that I just spoke about
is something that I
have to plan for, right?
So something that you
have to talk to people,
and you have to-- you start
collecting this data just
from the moment that
your implement them.
So that's very important
differentiation.
Now On the Fly
Segmentation is something
that you just had
an idea, and you
want to see data for this idea.
So if your data is organized,
you can find this information.
And again, we're going
to use User Segments,
and if you log into
Google Analytics,
you'll see the
same screen, right?
Now you have-- you want to see
people's behavior by an app
version, for example, that
I don't have a view for.
You can open on
the orange arrow.
Then you'll get this
interface, which
are-- those are the default
segments for mobile apps,
and basically, if you click here
on-- right I-- Tablet Traffic,
right?
You want to just, say,
people coming from tablets,
and then, you see all the
reports based on tablets,
so the behavior for
people using tablets.
Now you can also create
segments, so when you open it,
you will see that you have all
these dimensions that you can--
segment dimensions and metrics
that you can segment by--
and you can choose from a list
what kind-- so you want people
that, for example, came
to the web, to the app,
at least three times and spent
$50 across these three visits,
and you want to
see their behavior.
So that's a great way
to segment traffic,
and this is really not something
that you can build in advance,
so that's something On the Fly.
And the big advantage of
this On the Fly Segmentation
is-- first of all,
it's retroactive,
so you can see for
past behavior as well.
And we also have a
Solution Gallery, which
is a place where you can
download segments from,
and you can also
upload segments to,
and you can use the same
segments that your colleagues
are using, so it's
a very scalable way
to segment behavior.
And I like very much
this quote by Brandeis,
which is, "I abhor averages--"
All right, six meals one day
and zero the next is
not the same thing
as three meals one day
and three meals the other.
So if you do not
segment your traffic,
you're getting a very wrong
idea of what's going on.
So it's really, really important
to have segmentation in place.
Now let's go through
a few reports
that I find especially
insightful when
we talk about
analyzing app behavior.
And you can read
the-- so we have
to focus on the
right users, right?
That's, I think, the
single most important thing
on-- when we're dealing,
analyzing behavior
on our apps-- is to focus
on the right people.
And there is this report,
which is very nice.
It looks beautiful.
I like the charts, and
one very interesting thing
when you look at it--
that's the Loyalty Report--
is that, for example,
you can find things
like on the third
session, we can see a drop
in conversion rate, conversion
rates, which is amazing.
I mean there's
almost 60% conversion
rate on the second session,
and then it drops to 22,
and then it goes up to
50, and then 30, 43, 32,
so there is something very
wrong about the third session.
Maybe there is some
kind of pop up,
or something, that
is going wrong,
so that's a great way
to find where to focus.
So we are losing people on
this, on the third session,
and maybe there is something
that we are doing wrong there.
And another one is how
to prioritize, right?
And this is-- I'm sorry.
I'm just going back.
Oops-- Yeah so, if you
go to Audiences, and then
Devices and Network, Devices,
Operating Systems, Conversion.
That's a bit long, but you can
drop me an email afterwards,
and I'll just send you a link.
I'm sorry.
I think I-- Yeah, no.
I was trying-- OK.
I'm sorry.
So the previous report, it's
just some Behavior, Behavior,
and then Loyalty.
So that's the way you find
this, the Loyalty Report.
Now the next one is how
do we prioritize issues.
And here you can
see in our table
with operating system versions,
so this is Android, right?
4.3.
4.4.
And this is the average of the
conversion rate on the website.
Now what we can see is that 4.3
is 0.77% above the average when
it comes to conversion
rate, but then we
can see that 4.0.4 and 4.0.3,
we have significant drop
in conversion rates as well.
So that's a good
way-- should we invest
in supporting those
versions, and then you
should look at how many
people are using them,
and then you can do
the math by yourself,
if you should or
should not-- but that's
a great way to understand how
to prioritize those issues based
on conversion rates.
And our last one
is Behavioral Flow,
and this is great
to see where you
have bottlenecks on the app.
And you can see, for
example, here I'm
segmenting by app
version, so those
are the app versions
that I have.
And then you can
just click and see
the flow of your visitor
based on app version,
and you can see what
kind of bottlenecks
you have on the app.
Now some take aways.
First of all, plan
for segmentation.
I think it's really important
to see it with everyone--
the company, understand-- what
each person needs in terms
of Analytics, so if someone
uses only, as I mentioned, US,
is responsible only
for US traffic,
or for a certain campaign,
or for a certain version
of the app, you can create
a view for this person,
or for this department, so
that the person doesn't have
to spend so much time every
time that he or she comes
to Google Analytics.
Segment like crazy.
I think segmentation is the
most important thing when
it comes to Google Analytics,
so it's really important
to segment every time that
you come to Google Analytics,
so that it can understand
behavior in a better way.
Focus on the right users.
Prioritize development
by conversion.
I think it's a great way
to look at prioritization.
And optimize users'
experience using Analytics.
Now, before I end.
First of all, thank
you, Rupert Whitehead,
that put together the event,
which is very successful event.
And second, one of the things
that Rupert mentioned to us
was that we should think
about what kind of feedback
we'd like to get from you.
So I would really love to
talk to each one of you,
after the talk, about
those three things
that I would like to understand,
how you use Analytics.
So which kind of
report, or feature,
would help you make better
decisions using Analytics?
Who in your organization uses
Google Analytics, and are there
enough customizations
for different people that
use Analytics?
And third one, what
is the last time
that you made a
decision based on data?
Thank you, and happy analyzing.
[APPLAUSE]